ministers dear colleagues
I know I speak on behalf of the whole
College of commissioner when I say that
this visit is like no other
today we have come to the heart of
Europe because Ukraine has become the
center of our continent
the place where our values are upheld
where our freedom is defended
where the future of Europe is written
almost the entire College of the
European commission has come to give
today
because we want to write that future
together with you
and allow me to begin by honoring the
memory of those who should have been
with us today
if Russia's War had not tragically taken
them from us
the minister of interior Dennis
monasterski
first Deputy minister
yenin
state Secretary Yuri lupkovic she's
among others who lost their lives
and the best way to honor their memory
is through action
by turning their dream
into reality
today's visit is more than a meeting
between officials
it is one family coming together
we want to open a window to a brighter
future
while the present is incredibly hard and
demanding
Russian missiles keep being shot at your
cities
the Ukrainian people
and the Armed Forces keep fighting
bravely for their freedom and their
Homeland
so the great question we must tackle is
how we get from today's dark reality
to Ukraine's bright future inside the
European Union
how we can support Ukraine's struggle
for freedom and for Europe
we know that we can never match your
sacrifice
but the most immediate answer is that we
in the European Union
must continue
to step up the pressure on Russia
our measures are hitting at the core of
Russia's economy
Russia's gas revenues from Europe have
fallen by two-thirds compared to pre-war
levels
our price cap on crude oil costs Russia
around 160 million euros a day
and our sanctions are also cutting off
access to the high-tech items Putin
needs to sustain his military machine
today we will update you on the
implementation of our sanctions and how
we are working to make Russia pay
for the enormous damage and suffering it
is causing every single day
but of course
our support for Ukraine goes Way Beyond
sanctions
my colleagues and I are here today not
only to discuss further support
but also the next steps to bring Ukraine
even closer to the European Union
the fact
that we are meeting here today in Kiev
is a strong sign of the huge progress
already made and of our mutual
commitments
only one year ago
no one could ever made imagined how fast
Ukraine could move towards the European
Union
but now you are a candidate to joining
our Union
I know that millions of ukrainians are
working hard for that goal
we have many ukrainians that we host in
the European Union
our energy grids are synchronized
and thanks to the solidarity Lanes
Ukrainian farms and industries are
getting vital revenues by trading with
Europe and through Europe
today for instance we come with a set of
proposals to ensure Ukraine's seamless
access to the European single Market
we want to help Ukraine mobilize its
full economic potential in the fight
against Russia and later for
reconstruction
investors around the world are looking
at this country with admiration
and they're also looking at what still
needs to happen
our meeting today should also be a
message to investors
Ukraine will advance on its European
path
you have an ambitious reform agenda
not only because Europe asks for it
but because ukrainians know that the
path towards the European Union also
leads to a stronger Ukraine
dear colleagues
and the government and in the College of
Commissioners
I will never ever forget the day
when Ukraine became candidate country
the day
when the European flag was brought into
the Ukrainian Parliament
in a solemn ceremony
amid Thundurus Applause
it was a new beginning for Ukraine
but it was also a new beginning for the
European Union
your courage
has inspired us
you have given us a new sense of purpose
Europe is with you for as long as it
takes
until the day
when the Ukrainian flag
will be raised where it belongs
in Brussels in front of the Berlin at
the heart of the European Union Slava
Ukrainian
[Applause]
slow